[Music]
welcome this is the Ben Shapiro show
Sundays special this week's episode is
the intellectual dark web edition so on
this week's Sunday special gonna recap
some of the conversations I've had with
fellow members of the intellectual dark
web this is a term coined by my friend
Eric Weinstein basically the
intellectual dark web is just a bunch of
people with a wide variety of political
viewpoints who are willing to hash out
conversations in decent fashion now we
used to just call this America but
that's not the reality anymore the way
that it works in America now is that if
you disagree with any sort of prevailing
narrative you will immediately be
canceled a group of us sort of got
together in informal fashion originally
and then started talking and maybe
slightly more formal fashion it's really
a network of friends who are willing to
talk about things we disagree about like
sam harris and i we disagree about
nearly everything and eric weinstein
tonight we disagree about nearly
everything in joe rogan disagrees with
everybody about everything that's what
makes these conversations find it so it
makes the relationships fun see this
used to be part of the fun and games of
American politics and of American
thinking is that we would all pursue
truth together by examining each other's
ideas turning them over and debating
them with one another this obviously has
become such a unique phenomenon in
American public life that we actually
gave ourselves the name right Eric gave
us the name intellectual dark web it's
sort of stuck and then it grew and
they're a bunch of different figures who
are members or adjunct members of the
intellectual dark web
one of the things you're gonna hear us
talk about a lot here is the value of
freedom of speech freedom of association
freedom of discussion it's one of the
reasons the intellectual dark web
originally formed it's something there's
so many people really want to destroy I
call them disintegration in my new book
how to destroy America in three easy
steps that one is out July 21st was a
whole group of people in America who
believed that a culture of free speech
and discussion is really about power
differentials and preventing people who
are dispossessed from speaking that's an
absolute lie but it's become an
incredibly powerful talking point it's
why you see canceled culture on the rise
and I mean really on the rise these days
I talk about all that and how to destroy
America in three easy steps people ask
me what is the intellectual dark web all
think it is people who are open-minded
that's all people who are willing to
have conversations that you're really
not supposed to have these and by that I
mean any conversation at all and that
means that a lot of the people in this
group are liberals I believe I'm the
only person in the group who plans on
voting for Trump in 2020 it's funny the
media have obviously characterized the
entire group as rabid right-wing fascist
which is unbelievable you're talking
about in Brett Weinstein a socialist in
Eric a quasi socialist you're talking
about in sam harris a lifelong democrat
with joe rogan you're talking about a
guy who alternatively would vote for
Bernie Sanders or maybe Donald Trump or
whoever the hell knows right Joe kind of
switches on a moment's notice
you got Jordan Peterson who might be
considered conservative except that he's
Canadian and doesn't vote in American
elections you got Dave Rubin who was a
gay liberal who became a gay quasi
conservative so it's all over the place
the intellectual dark web but it gained
importance again at a time when canceled
culture seems to be in the offing when
he gave I think people a sense of
comfort that yeah maybe we actually can
talk with one another it's the
distinction I commonly make on my own
show between the left and liberals I say
that there are people who I know who I
like who are liberals they disagree with
me on everything but they are still
willing to stand up for my right to say
things and then there's Leftwich which
is to just shut down all conversation in
fascistic fashion and make sure that
nobody can ever say anything in this
episode you're gonna hear me talk with
my friends Joe Rogan Sam Harris Jordan
Peterson Eric Weinstein and christina
hoff sommers all of these people are
very controversial I'm not supposed to
be friendly with them but each of these
conversations was a blast we actually
are all friends off the air as well I
think you'll enjoy this window into the
kind of conversations that we actually
do have in real life these ones are just
on camera
the last compilation Sunday's special we
made was on the topic of judeo-christian
values one of the people we talked to in
that conversation was my friend Michael
Shermer looking back on being part of
the Sunday special and being part of
that conversation Michael wrote us this
letter quote my conversation with Ben
was one of the best I've had among the
thousands of media interviews I've done
over the past quarter century one reason
is it wasn't an interview but a
conversation Ben is one of the most
informed minds I've encountered in a
long time the fastest talker west of the
Mississippi the toughest man south of
the picket wire next to me to quote John
Wayne's character tom doniphon
describing the scoreless Liberty valance
in me shot even though Ben and I
disagree on many things we agree on the
most important thing of all the free
speech and open dialog are the royal
road to truth and I suspect he would
like me reject the sentiment
one of the most memorable lines in
filmic history when the legend becomes
fact print the legend not only do facts
not care about your feelings as Ben says
facts also don't care about your legend
I can't wait to face Ben again high noon
on Main Street in shinbone Arizona
I appreciate that Michael we hope to
hear from some of the other guests that
we've talked to over some of these prior
shows and we can give you their
reactions to the conversations which I
think are really fascinating in some
cases maybe they'll what about some of
my points we'll bring those to you when
they come in it turns out you don't have
to agree with everybody in order to get
along with everybody and if we all had a
little bit more of that you too can be a
member of the intellectual dark web
again what we just used to call First
Amendment normal conversation in the
United States so I hope you really enjoy
the episode these conversations were
some of the most stimulating that we've
had on the Sunday special specifically
because there was disagreement and
good-natured disagreement about the
biggest issues in life from me talking
about atheism and religion with Sam
Harris to me talking about free markets
with Eric Weinstein I mean it's just all
over the place and that's the fun of it
it's freewheeling and it's interesting
it is the podcast arena I mean I will
say the podcasting has made this sort of
stuff possible the Internet has made
this sort of stuff possible which is why
you're seeing the left seeking to crack
down on the Internet and the means of
distribution on the Internet that's why
we all have to fight back against all of
that so with that said I hope you
enjoyed this episode of the Ben Shapiro
show Sunday special compilation from the
intellectual dark web we're gonna jump
into it all in just a moment but first I
want to take a moment to give a shout
out to all of our advertising partners
who make this show possible and we
definitely appreciate that our listeners
do business with our advertising
partners that too keeps the show going
and keeps those businesses going we're
all trying to get through this rough
time together you me our show's
advertising partners so let's talk about
one of them policy genius they've
introduced another winning combination
an exclusive life insurance policy with
affordable rates and a hassle-free
application life insurance is made of
paper but this new policy makes getting
life insurance so easy you'll actually
enjoy it
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price you could save up
to 1500 bucks or more a year by using
policy genius to compare life insurance
policies and this exclusive new policy
makes things even easier now qualified
applicants can complete their medical
requirements over the phone so if you
need life insurance but you don't know
where to start get started at policy
genius
calm minutes you'll be able to compare
quotes find the right coverage and apply
you'll get the right life insurance
coverage and the best shopping
experience to winning a combination
policy genius it's nice to get it right
by the way if you are a responsible
human being you got a family you got to
make sure that your family is covered in
case god forbid something should happen
to you this is why you need all the
insurance you could possibly use and you
can get all of it for the most
competitive price over at policy genius
com no lines no red tape no waiting just
go to policy genius comm right now get
it taken care of policy genius it's nice
to get insurance right policy genius
comm one of our first guests to join the
show is Joe Rogan from episode four
Joe's been a stand-up comedian for
twenty years and then a commentator for
almost as long today he's arguably most
well known for his podcast the Joe Rogan
experience a long-form conversation
style interview show that features
guests from all walks of life includes
some of the biggest names in politics
technology and entertainment multiple
times a week often multiple times a day
he sits down for hours with people like
Bernie Sanders Elon Musk Robert Downey
jr. and Hawaa what started as a simple
web stream backstage of his comedy shows
has grown into a landmark of the
podcasting industry the Joe and I had
become pretty good friends I will say
that Joe is one the most fun people I
know one of the most open-minded and
dudes a kick I mean he really is when he
came to the studios obviously everybody
was really enthusiastic about seeing Joe
Rogan because after all he has this
enormous crowd and he's just the most
down-to-earth dude I know I love the
fact that Joe is down-to-earth and he
really doesn't take his fame and fortune
for granted but you would never know
just met him on the street that he was
famous and incredibly wealthy he really
is an incredible guy I'm a big Joe Rogan
fan and I'm proud to consider him a
personal friend here Joe and I discussed
how his podcast got started how cultural
differences affect the ongoing race
conversation the effectiveness of the
American political system and his
controversial opinion on voting which I
kind of agree with
[Music]
you're really gifted guy but you can you
can sit there for three hours with
somebody and talk about the most random
topic and make it really interesting so
I need the backstory so all of my
listeners and and people who are fans of
mine might not know your work as well
might not know kind of your story so how
did you get to be doing what you're
doing right now like give it give us the
whole history well with the podcasting
it just started out doing a video thing
with just Ustream we're just doing two
and a like people would tweet questions
we'd ask answer questions just for fun I
did it once and actually did it a couple
of times backstage in between shows
years before that there's a thing called
justin.tv which I'm not sure what that
is now became a new company but we would
just show backstage we'd have like a web
cam going and would just play around and
talk to people and have fun and then we
did the one Q&A and I said I'm gonna do
it again next week we'll try to do it
regularly so I did it again the next
Monday and then it became a weekly thing
that we started uploading it to iTunes
and then we started getting guests and
then I said okay I gotta get out of my
house and do all these weirdos were
coming over my house like I'll just get
a studio somewhere so I got a studio and
then after the studio mic well the
studio is kind of little let's get a
bigger studio so then I got a bigger
studio and then now it's somehow another
it's a business there's a deep desire
right now in a free society to try and
figure out why some people succeed and
some people fail and we're never allowed
to say that there are natural issues at
stake and and some and I understand the
resistance to based on race right so for
example you see a lot of people who will
say you can't ever talk about racial
differences in IQ because that is going
to lead to toward this racist conclusion
that your race defines your IQ which is
you know a silly conclusion like there
are racial differences in IQ based on
kind of group statistics that has no
relevance to the particular individual
standing in front of you and so you
saying this black guy is stupid because
he's black is racist
you saying their group differences in IQ
because every study ever done is showing
group differences in IQ not even based
on racial groups necessarily based on
different groups generally between
between you know age groups there are
differences in IQ actually if you if you
show that at least from young age to to
like 12
if you
you mention any of these things then
you're overriding the idea of a tabula
rasa human being who can be created in
whatever image you want like what people
really want is to correct the cosmic
imbalances as Thomas Olsen's I know what
do you think is behind it I think the I
think you're hitting the nail on the
head and I I think there's a tremendous
amount of white guilt involved in it as
well I mean because basically what the
IQ tests are showing when they do study
differences in IQ and and races you're
showing the rise of the superiority of
the Asian race I mean Asians dominate
those things and everybody is so just
like well that's that's what's not
talked about that let's talk about white
and black because that's more convenient
and it's easier and they could find a
victim and they could find a perpetrator
and what you're also seeing like there's
a lot of Asian groups that are furious
because they're getting discriminated
against about getting into colleges and
universities they have higher standards
because they have such a high percentage
of Asians that are getting into the
universities and it's it's very strange
because they're not vocal about it and
they're not they're not publicizing it
and they're not screaming racism in the
streets but they're the victims of it
they actually the victims of hard work
and success and excellent genetics right
well there's no question and the
differences in culture are really the
place where we should be putting most of
our focus because when it comes to you
know natural imbalances there's only so
much that you can do right I'm not gonna
be fighting you in a ring anytime soon
said just get destroyed but the same
that but when it comes to cultural
differences that's the stuff that we can
correct for and instead of doing now
what we tend to do is we tend to pretend
that the cultural differences are not
brought about by immediate
decision-making by parents or by
immediate communities it's it's
something out there right it's it's
racism in the ether or it's
discrimination writ large it's something
it's something out there we can't we
can't put our heads around it exactly
but something that's making us imbalance
and so the way to fix that is by getting
rid of all imbalances that we see and so
if there's an imbalance between men and
women we'll just pretend that that
doesn't exist anymore and that it must
have been caused by something that we
can't quite control yeah it's definitely
not an objective way of approaching the
issue I think there's a host of
different factors that play into every
community right there's the the echoes
of the poor be
a view of the people that live there
before you all the consequences of other
people's actions that have affected all
the people around you people going to
jail people that have experienced racism
people that have experienced poor
treatment by law enforcement massive
distrust around you very difficult to
excel in those environments you're
constantly like running away from gangs
and headed home I don't think we should
hold those people up to the same
standards as we should people that grow
up in very safe middle-class communities
where they don't have to worry about all
this stuff I think there's a bunch of
different factors and everybody's
looking for one only the one factor that
appeals to their ideology yeah and
that's a real problem it's a problem
also any time you mention IQ everybody
goes nuts yes immediately they suggest
that what you're saying is is racist and
the truth is that whatever IQ
differentials there are it's unclear and
how much is explained by genetics and
how much is explained by environment but
some is clearly explained by genetics
and some is clearly explained by
environment as soon as you say that
everybody suggests that you are
operating in a racist space so it's as
you say when it comes to data like this
happened with Sam Harris when he was
being interviewed by Ezra Klein as a
reclined just went after him for
suggesting that science is science well
science is still science even if you
don't like the science and Jim's like
the same thing should apply when it
comes to biological differences do you
want to see a more active government or
a less active government because I'm
kind of happy with the gridlock I'll be
honest with you I kind of like the fact
the government in doing anything there's
definitely some pros to that I think it
would be better if we had a more
competent system and I agree with you
that the checks and balances have we've
shown that he can't just throw
everything out and and just run Trump
mania all across the country I think
there's definitely some some positive to
that gridlock so it's okay so what
changes would you make to the system
because you talked about the system
being being processed you talked about
online voting do you mean online voting
direct on issues or you mean online
voting for representatives all the above
okay so you like the referendum system
in California I think if you have
opinions on things I mean first of all
this is really unpopular I think you
should have to show that you have an
understanding of what you're voting on
you should probably have online with
yeah if you want to get rid of the idea
requirements and retain the actual you
need to know what you're talking about
retirement I think I could
I think you should take a test and if
you understand what what the
consequences of your decision are you
understand what what is being voted on
then you can vote on it but if you just
read if you just go check yes check no
just do it haphazard just because you're
a crazy person
and you happen to be 18 I think that's
pretty ridiculous and but to have a test
and have someone say well you have to be
you have to be required to understand
have a rudimentary understanding of what
you're talking about in order to make an
opinion that could literally affect 300
million people a lot of people would say
that's bad because then what about are
you are you saying that people have to
have a certain intelligence level in
order to vote is this like you did are
you at the door of eugenics like what do
you where you going with this well I
think it's not a bad idea to say that if
you're gonna vote on really important
issues like whatever those issues are
whether it's funding the military or
abortion or whatever it is you should
have an understanding of the subject I
don't think that's unreasonable but
people don't want any extra work and
they they want things to be very very
convenient
they want the virtually signalling also
being able to have voting right now is
just virtually signalling like
demonstrations the public at large to
people at large what this vote means to
you so is Hillary Clinton campaigning on
if you vote for me you'll show that you
voted for a woman and if you vote for
Barack Obama you've shown that you vote
for a black guy if you're voting for
Donald Trump you're sticking a middle
finger to the system itself symbolic
voting very little of it seems to be
about like what's just actually gonna do
one see there no and that's that's a
that's a serious problem
one of the biggest episodes ever on
Joe's podcast was with our next guest
Jordan Peterson Jordan is a professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto
which is where he was when his first
book maps of meaning the architecture
and belief came out Jordans career took
a new direction in 2016 when he became a
vocal critic of a new law passed in
Canada Bill c16 which made gender
identity and expression prohibited
grounds of discrimination
Jordan published a youtube series on the
law and argue to his compelled speech
meaning it was requiring people to
express thoughts they disagree with the
series created tons of controversy and a
lot of media coverage for Jordan
Jordan's second book the bestseller 12
rules for life an antidote to chaos was
still quite new when he joined me on the
premiere episode of the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special over the course of 2018
the book exploded it sold 3 million
copies around the world which took
Jordan around the globe speaking to
hundreds of thousands of people and made
him a household name Jordan is an
incredible incredible guy one of the
things I love most about Jordan is that
he really is in person exactly the same
way that he is when he speaks he's
introspective he is thoughtful he
listens I've gotten personal book
recommendations from Jordan I've taken
them to heart I think that Jordan has an
incredible amount of wisdom and honestly
one of the most humble people I know for
about a year now Jordan has been going
through some challenging medical times
we've been happy to hear he's doing a
lot better our thoughts and prayers are
with him and his family hopefully we'll
see his quick recovery and get a chance
to sit down and talk with him soon again
from our Sunday special listen to Jordan
give the argument that the human race
determines the direction of evolution
through their logos their consciousness
and how we have to value the individual
in order to build up and maintain the
structure of society or face the
consequences of society becoming
totalitarian he and I also discussed the
debate of free will and how the
existence of consciousness informs it
[Music]
well we already walked through the fact
that the heroes of the past acted on
potential to extract out the world of
actuality and if they did that properly
then the world they extracted was good
and that that is a Divine Principle and
then we might say well is it a Divine
Principle and you might say well what is
it that's acting through people in the
good like the Christian theological
answer to that would be the logos right
that's the idea that's the idea of the
holy spirit roughly speaking right might
think well is that a real thing it's
like well to me it's real the same way
that consciousness is real and we don't
know the role of consciousness in
determining reality even but even if
you're an evolutionary biologist and
this is so interesting because the
evolutionary biologists actually
discriminate differentiated themselves
from Darwin on this point like Darwin
was very very forthright in his claim
that sexual selection was as powerful as
natural selection or even more so and so
that so here's where this that goes and
and because that was because that
brought consciousness into the world as
an active player the materialistic
evolutionary biologist ignored that so
like 150 years and only concentrated on
natural selection where they could play
well this is all chance right it's like
sexual selection is not chance okay so
here's a hypothesis human being
separated themselves from chimpanzees
one of the reasons they did that was
because human females are sexually
selective chimps aren't chimps will
female chimps in estrus will mate with
any chimp the main chimps the dominant
ones chased the subordinate males away
so they're more likely to have offspring
but it's not because of female choice
right now female human females have done
this whole different thing is that
they've they've they have hidden
fertility and they're much more likely
to go after guys who have climbed up the
hierarchy so let's say heroes will give
the women some credit for intelligence
right and say that that's what they're
after
even if they're using wealth and so
forth and status as a marker they're
actually using those as a marker for
competence standed yeah and I think
that's I think yeah I think the evidence
for that is clear okay so you might say
oh well it was human
female conscious choice that selected us
okay and you think well that's not
random that's not random at all it's the
farthest thing from random that there is
and that means consciousness is making
its choices with regards to what
propagates but then it's even more
complex than that so here's what happens
among men the men all get together in
their hierarchy they positive valued
goal they all accept that as the goal
because otherwise they wouldn't be
cooperating right then they arrange
themselves into a hierarchy and they let
the most competent guys lead because
they want to get to they want to get to
the promised land they want to get it
the most competent leaders leading by
competent defined by that value okay so
here's what happens essentially the men
all get together and vote on the good
man and the good man are then chosen by
the women and those are the people who
propagate and so it's like men are
voting on which men get to reproduce and
women are going along with the vote and
and and being even more stringent in
their in their choices let's say and so
then what you get is that the
consciousness that through its active
expression transforms the potential of
the world into actuality also selects
the direction of evolution right and
that's where the meme darkens term turns
into the biological reality it's not so
it yeah this is something that's so cool
about Dawkins it's like I've often
thought this about Dawkins is if he
would push his thinking to the limits he
would fall right into young well and
then he'd be lost that's a whole other
universe but if you think that mean
seriously like and I mean really
seriously think yeah there's some ways
of conceptualizing that becomes so
all-encompassing yeah that's right they
start to become an actual force of
evolution itself and so then here's the
case you could make consciousness
extracts the proper world of being from
potential through truth and then it's
good this way okay that's our hard one
man that manifests itself in human
beings at the individual level of
individual consciousness that's the
logos with it that's the metaphysical
foundation of the
of natural right and responsibility
that's a bloody killer idea that's
expressed in the hero of Heroes that
idea that hero of Heroes is the driving
force behind human evolution so not only
do you get the action of the logos
metaphysically as the process that
extracts order out of chaos at the
beginning of time you also get it as the
major driver of evolution and so then
you last okay then what kind of reality
does that have because you chase
consciousness back and like it
disappears into the mystery of our past
and we have no idea what its
relationship is with matter but it's the
force that gives rise to the cosmos and
drives evolution it's like you're
getting pretty close to God there yeah
even just pragmatically speed and you're
certainly you know not close to but in
the midst of an argument about freewill
because obviously if you if you make the
hard determinist argument that freewill
doesn't exist and the consciousness is
merely a sort of trick that your brain
is playing on itself then how exactly
does how does culture propagate how do
we how do these memes propagate how are
people choosing hmm sexual selection of
natural selection become one of the same
as soon as you boil sexual selection
down to natural selection oh well you
know so I think the freewill argument I
mean I see why Harris gets tangled up in
that you know because well first of all
deterministic arguments are unbelievably
powerful and when we use deterministic
models for many things they really were
right so you could say well we're gonna
use that by defaults like fair enough
we're gonna deviate from that with care
but I don't see people as driven like
clocks winding down first of all we
don't wind down in any simple way we're
dissipative structures to use he wrote
rhodium what is life a human being is a
dissipative structure we're not we're
not an entropic structure like a clock
running down we are in some sense but as
living beings we pull energy in and so
we're not winding down like a
deterministic structure or something
other than that and the way we treat
each other is as logos as far as I can
tell the way I treat myself right if I'm
going to be good to myself in the proper
sense is that I'm an active agent of
choice confronting an infinite landscape
of potential and casting that potential
into a reality for good or
for eBay okay and if I treat myself that
way then I have proper respect for
myself and proper fear of myself because
I can make bad decisions and warp the
structure of reality and I think if you
read Frankel for example or Solzhenitsyn
and you see how your bad decisions can
warp the structure of reality then that
wakes you up right okay so there's that
if you don't treat yourself like an an
active agent imbued with logos then your
life doesn't go well but more if you
don't treat other people that way they
do not want to play with you if we set
up societies that aren't predicated on
the idea that people are like that then
the societies become they dissolve or
they become totalitarian almost
instantly so then I would say well
you've got the problem of determinism
it's like fair enough man how do you
reconcile the fact that if you lay out a
society at every level of analysis on
strict deterministic grounds it fails
so doesn't doesn't that mean your
hypothesis has a flaw I mean maybe not
maybe you could say no the facts are
independent of the ethical contract
exactly this is where the truth deterred
this is where the truth pragmatism
question is back into being written
Samos say well it's true regardless of
what the effect is hmm and you would say
well it's obviously not true if morals
aren't constructed for a pragmatic
reason and if this fragment isn't it'll
work if it falls into nothing and also
it also depends to some degree on what
you're willing to how you're willing to
test your hypothesis because I might say
well if your hypothesis is factually
correct wouldn't you assume that if
people based their their their their
behaviors individually and familial and
socially on that set of facts which is
basically what Sam claims about facts to
do in with if you base your ethos on
that those facts wouldn't it work right
well he claims that that's a test and I
would say well then it fails that test
yeah it doesn't work we have to treat
each other like divine Centers of
consciousness in order for society to
work yes I think well that's I can't see
any way out of those arguments Sam
Harris's writings and lectures span a
wide array of topics neuroscience moral
philosophy religion human violence
rationality but mainly they focus on how
understanding more about ourselves in
the world around us changes our sense of
how we should live he's written five New
York Times bestsellers the end of faith
Leonard - a Christian nation the moral
landscape waking up and Islam and the
future of tolerance Sam also hosts the
podcast making sense with Sam Harris
where he explores important questions
about the human mind society and current
events as a practicing meditator for
over 30 years
Sam created the waking up app for those
who wish to learn to meditate in a
modern scientific context Sam and I
agree on a lot but we do tend to come at
things from very different angles Sam of
course is a self-proclaimed atheist I
actually mentioned near the end of our
interview how I wish we could go on for
another couple of hours discussing how
our beliefs shape our world views and
opinions it's such an interesting at
conversation and one of the things that
I really like about Sam is that Sam is a
practical thinker he is very very clear
in his thinking he doesn't like to muddy
the waters net clarity is really
informative it leads to really
fascinating conversations in which it is
pretty obvious what we believe some
people who are philosophers tend to try
and hide the ball not Sam Sam is very
blunt about what he believes and that's
some
I greatly appreciate about him
personally with that said listen to some
of episode 9 where Sam and I cover
whether his success and the success of
the intellectual dark web generally
makes him optimistic or pessimistic for
the future of the country Sam also
argues for why rationality is the most
important elements of persuasion we have
when we talk with other people
[Music]
what we should all be anchored to is a
good faith intellectually honest non
smear merchants approach to analyzing
what we think we know and why we think
we know it and those principles of
rationality and an empirical engagement
with with reality simply are not
susceptible to an identity or even a
political interpretation I mean this is
just this is why reason is the only
thing that scales if if I have a good
enough argument based on clear enough
evidence it should persuade you if you
are you being reasonable no matter
what's your background no matter who
your parents were no matter how you were
mistreated or not as a child you know if
we build a reasonable robot it should be
persuaded by the right arguments and the
right data so it rationality is is the
mode of argument where it doesn't depend
who you are in order to in order to
reach the right answer what do you think
that the United States is going because
obviously we've seen you know the rise
of your audience is enormous you have a
huge audience I think a lot of folks you
mentioned Joe Rogan has an enormous
audience Jordan Peterson obviously has a
very big audience a lot of these people
have a very big audience do you think
that the the rise of these new
conversations is are you optimistic you
pessimistic do you think that these new
conversations are going to turn into a
new sort of brand of politics that ends
up saving the country or are you
pessimistic and you think that ya
density politics machines that are now
operating at seemingly full blast on all
sides do you think that those end up
winning the day for the moment I don't
know yeah I really just the future is a
big question mark for me because because
the present is fundamentally surprising
to me I didn't think we would get Trump
yeah there's almost nothing and and
getting Trump I didn't think we would
get the kind of reaction we see to Trump
and I could have predicted the reaction
on the left but it just amazes me every
day that he is as untouchable based on
his own
missteps and and gaffes and you know
crazy utterances which is the fact that
nothing sticks to him it surprises me
every day so
I don't quite know how we got here I
think we I think you and I will be fine
right now I'm very optimistic about our
having conversations like this and this
this channel and media would be having a
durable interest for people but whether
it will affect any real political change
in the near term I don't know because I
see the left is fully capable of playing
a a what should be a fairly good hand so
badly is to just amplify you know white
populism and and trumpism for you well
beyond Trump's next four years I just
think it's a bit there's there's no
mistake so idiotic that the left isn't
capable and that a and I'm you know as
you point out or as we'll discover I'm
you know I'm on the left on virtually
every relevant question except except
the ones we've been talking about which
is you know the virtues of identity
politics and and victimology rationality
I think I said I might have said this to
you on stage at our event right
rationality is not a the successful
moments of reasoning are not examples
where freedom of will is even tempting
to ascribe I mean so it's it's if I give
you an argument you have if you strongly
believe one thing and I give you an
argument that persuades you that just
knocks down the row of dominoes in your
mind it leads you to think I understand
it's a naturalistic response to a
reasonable argument that mean control
over that but you you don't have any
control over over any moment where you
finally see the light so I give you a
chain of reasoning and it works you
would it that that's a moment where you
are changed by something extrinsic to
your own volition so my basic response
to that is yes and no because you see
people who clearly resist the impact of
a reasonable argument well themselves
that's what the resistance is what it is
to be unreasonable or to be under this
way of wishful thinking or compromise
the bottom line is that from my
perspective that is somebody if the idea
is that reason is basically just
eliciting a particular response then
people have the capacity to override
their ability to listen to reason but
okay so if you're gonna
crime that to free will that's that's a
different thing to ascribe but that
again I would wouldn't you don't need
freewill to explain that but that's that
is take the reasoning piece if I give
you a the quintessential moment of it I
give you a column of numbers to add up
right you have zero degrees of freedom
if you're going to actually be doing
arithmetic so then the question is to
the final question here because we and
for we're gonna have to have you in for
like a four hour session here in just
moves but it's but is the argument in
favor of reason a moral reason is good
argument or is the argument a
utilitarian reason is useful argument or
is it both because I can imagine a lot
of ways to convince people of things
that don't involve me making arguments
to them and the historically have been
used to great success with horrible
horrific human carnage obviously well
you're not necessarily convincing them
in that case you're just forcing them
yeah that's right the although I would
say that you can indoctrinate fully
millions of people interpret it you
would think this to right that it's
possible to doctrine a people not using
reason and to fully form belief systems
yeah so is it so when you make the
argument for reason are you saying that
reason is morally better and if so why
is reason morally better than for
example the appeal of passion which has
obviously motivated millions of billions
of people over done right well I I don't
think they're separable as many people
think I think you can't reason and
there's neurological evidence to back
this up and Antonio Damasio did this
work decades ago where if you have
certain neurological injuries in the
right or bone medial prefrontal cortex
you can't you can't be moved by the
products of your quote reasoning because
I've been reason has to be anchored to
emotion in a very direct way and you can
actually feel this in yourself so if I
say something it starts to sound like
bull to you right that feeling of doubt
you know the feeling that you have
detected errors in my chain of reasoning
that feels like something that is an
emotion right and if you couldn't feel
that you know it was all just cold and
calculating and just as I sociopaths you
know can't reason their way to virtually
anything well they can writ well or we
can't can reason their way to everything
they could they can they can reason fine
unfortunately they just don't care about
other people's experience so they're
they're very they're they're very
manipulative in ways that you and I
wouldn't the reason itself doesn't
arrive at a moral answer in any case so
for me reason is the only
thing that yeah as we talked about at
the top of this it's the only thing that
it takes us out of who we are and scales
to some universal point of view it's
it's not it's it's you're not reasoning
if you're actually reasoning what you're
arriving at is not just true for you
it's true for anyone who could be in its
true form essentially above on any given
topic you know it does offer the view
from above or the view from any possible
perspective or at least it takes in the
into account the effect of perspective
you know so it's like if you know again
reason is and scientific rationality
generally is the thing that explains why
you know if you're color blind
you don't see colors the way I do right
and that's it but it's not that we can't
get at what's actually real we can we
could because we can explain divergences
of opinion it's and and otherwise you
just have those divergences Christina
Hoff Sommers has spent her career
defending classic first wave feminism
and critiquing modern feminism she's
known as the factual feminist and hosts
a blog by the same name where she uses a
data-driven approach to cover all
subjects related to feminist
philosophies and practices including the
me2 movement microaggressions the wage
gap and the supposed patriarchy as a
resident scholar at the American
Enterprise Institute dr. Sommers also
studies free expression due process and
the preservation of Liberty in the
Academy previously she was a philosophy
professor at Clark University and has
written books such as freedom feminism
it's surprising history and why it
matters today and the war against boys
which we'll get into here christina is
just a delight she is upbeat she is
optimistic and again she's a very very
data-driven which is something I think
everyone in the intellectual dark web is
I mean if you are going to convince
somebody of your argument you have to
present data and that is something
christina hoff sommers
is very much into she sort of been
mischaracterized as a classical
conservative I don't think that dr.
Summers considers herself that way and
you'll see some interesting
disagreements along the way in this
particular episode in this segment from
episode 18 christina covers the failings
of the women's movement to find common
ground amongst all women how we're going
to thrive if we develop the men in our
society and where we need to put our
focus to do this and why focusing on men
in turn is going to help women
[Music]
well the thing is that women's problems
are talked about a lot because for good
reason we had a women's movement we have
lots of organizations everywhere and I
actually see more problems for men right
now and men don't have a Lobby
especially little boys and I wrote a
book the war against boys what's
happening with little boys in school so
right now I'm the mainly concerned about
the men and you know that the vast
numbers of men in prison the the boys
that are dropping out of school the men
that have not just dropped it that
aren't just unemployed they're not
looking for work we've got you know
able-bodied men in their prime earning
years who are not in the workforce and
we have an educational system that is
not meeting the needs of men as well as
women and and when I look at women's
problems because women do have serious
problems especially the feminization of
poverty if you are alone with children
it's very hard for women and given the
job as women do and so it's they need
men we need each other so I don't really
see it as separate at this point I think
we need kind of a an egalitarian
movement and that looks at areas where
we could help men because when you help
men you help women at this point in the
United States and and and if you help
women you help man
we need to we're in this together so the
problem of poverty the problem of single
motherhood and all that you've got us
they've got to be marriage able men
they've got to be guys and it's not
enough just to it used to be you could
graduate from high school and work hard
you could make it into the middle class
now you you almost required to have
college beyond high school
some specialization and far more women
are getting that than men so we may end
up closing the wage gap just by having a
better educated women but socially that
is not the projections are not good for
a stable society it's not good for the
workforce and other countries are
addressing that problem so anyway I do
see a problem the financial problem with
women but I think it's connected to men
the most serious problems for women
though as you said
they're not in the West I think there
are many parts of the world where they
have not had two major waves of feminism
they haven't had so much as a trickle
and I go to international women's
conferences and I meet women coming from
you know Somalia and Egypt and Iran
which is a kind of you know talk about a
Handmaid's Tale and that's like 1984 for
women and in many ways that although
it's terrible for men too but but I meet
the women that are that are sort of the
freedom fighters that the Elizabeth Cady
Stanton and Susan B Anthony and
Sojourner Truth of those countries and
it's very exciting but American women
right now especially on the campus who
have so much to give and who are so
gifted and you know there you are at
Wellesley and you're at swath and
they're turned in on their own
oppression and not making common cause
with these women around the world that
didn't need help and they come to these
conferences they want help from American
women because we did liberate ourselves
and they want to do the same and I don't
understand why our women's movement
wouldn't be so focused on making those
connections and you know you go back in
the 80s on the college campus with our
part ID in South Africa and you know the
students were very focused on the social
justice in South Africa where are they
today on gender apartheid in in you know
Saudi Arabia or something they're mostly
talking about apartheid gender apartheid
in the Girl Scouts and Boy Scouts or you
know that we have separate you know the
language is all about in of crisis for
our society which is not a patriarchy
notes come back to the United States for
a second it seems to me one of the big
problems that I've seen particularly
among men since we're gonna talk about
men is this feeling of a lack of purpose
and that seems like that's been
exacerbated a lot by the false
perceptions regarding gender and sex
that my contention has always been that
young men particularly either create or
destroy and there's not a lot in between
and I can see it with my two and a half
year old boy he's a building blocks or
he's knocking them down those are the
only two things that he's doing in any
given time and usually he's knocking
them down usually he's just a suicide
machine he's trying to kill himself
full-time and it's my job to stop him
from doing that and a society that they
to recognize that men actually have to
be thrust into positions of
responsibility including the
responsibility to protect women
shouldn't be all that surprised when it
turns out that men are destructive in
the absence of those responsibilities
well all societies who want to thrive
and survive have to spend and have spent
a lot of time civilizing their young
males yeah because if you don't do that
they have some very unpleasant ways of
making themselves noticed and if you
have a lot of sort of under socialized
young men they they can develop and and
there is a I don't like to use the term
anymore but they say toxic masculinity
I'll call it protest masculinity and a
young man that's in that mode will show
his masculinity by destroying by tearing
down by preying on vulnerable people and
in fact it's just the opposite of
healthy masculinity healthy men who
admits a healthy masculinity they don't
destroy they build they create they
invent and they protect and in you know
societies everywhere men have largely
been the protectors and the Warriors and
you know defend from attack and and they
defend there are a small number of men
who are the Predators and they did they
offend the society from them and we put
effort into that how do you get these
young men to develop a happy healthy
masculinity well helps to have a father
we don't hear that much about fathers in
fact you often hear that denigrated in a
you know oh that's just an old-fashioned
idea that children need fathers well
they do and your lovely boys especially
it seems to take an extra toll they've
looked at single-family homes and the
girls overall fare better because first
of all they have this heroic mother
who's working so hard they pay and the
boy finds his identity elsewhere so you
need the father and then there are ways
through sports and through athletics and
so forth with a coach and there are ways
to focus that energy and that you know
creative into healthy masculinity now
overall we've done a pretty good job I
mean we don't like to admit it but most
people
are not out committing crimes and you
know it's all gone down we're doing
something right but we are what we're
really failing where I see we're failing
most seriously is engaging young men
academically and I see a lot of evidence
that our schools are increasingly they
favor people you know this the kids who
can who are happy to be sedentary and
you know talk about their feelings
there's a lot of lot of writing and
reading is about shared feelings and and
so a kid that comes in that likes
rough-and-tumble play and likes you know
can't sit still and takes it there it's
almost as if girls are the gold standard
and boys are being measured and they're
not so their first experience with
school is frustration and sometimes
failure much higher rates of boys
getting suspended and thrown out even in
preschool so people say well I mean we
don't as I said before we don't have
these groups we don't have activist
groups for boys we have a lot for women
and girls and they've done good that if
it's done a lot of good I mean we were
faltering in math and science and boy
have we improved the quality of math and
science education for girls where were
the programs for boys who are behind in
reading all the scores show I mean the
boys score like slightly better in math
but a girl's score higher in reading
around the world you need to put extra
effort into engaging a boy in the world
of the written word where is that in
these schools of Education where they're
still teaching I don't know you know
radical theories about women's
oppression know they're not learning it
so there's a whole field there's a lot
of work to be done I tell it when I go
to schools yeah there's a lot of work
like male pedagogy how to teach boys and
they're already starting in Australia
and Canada because they're worried about
their workforce they don't want to have
you know 20 or 25 percent of it you know
men you know in some you know who can't
cope in an information economy so there
we could look at what the Australians
and the British are doing
I don't know if you tried to do it
they'd say that's backlash that's the
patriarchy you speak no it's not I don't
want to speak that language anymore I
don't think it's helpful what's helpful
is to recognize one another men and
women as as I said just working together
and mutual civility and respect and even
love has been known to happen
the term intellectual darkweb was first
coined by Eric Weinstein who said he was
half joking at the time but the name
stuck
becoming popular after a New York Times
article by Barry Weiss highlighted
supposing members of the group four of
whom we've talked to here and includes
yours truly as well eric is a managing
director of teal capital in San
Francisco and a research fellow at the
mathematical Institute of Oxford
University he speaks and publishes on a
variety of topics including gauge Theory
immigration the market for elite labor
management of financial risk and the
incentivizing of risk-taking in science
eric is maybe the smartest dude I know
just on a raw IQ level eric is nearly
impossible to compete with eric is all
over the place and he has fun to talk to
because he's all over the place I feel
like I spend most of my time talking
with Eric trying to bring him down to a
level where I can understand him which
actually makes for some pretty great
conversation when we do it publicly
because Eric will be floating above the
earth 30,000 feet in a hot-air balloon
and I'm trying to drag him down with a
rope so people can understand what the
hell he's talking about
but he's really sophisticated in his
approach to science and politics and
human thought he's really open-minded
and just a fascinating all-around dude
in this conversation from episode 11
Eric and I discussed where the name and
concept behind the intellectual dark web
came from why it's perceived to be a
right-wing group when I'm the only
registered Republican and how the
dangerous strains of leftism have
invaded news and media universities
intact
[Music]
so Eric first of all welcome thanks for
coming thanks for everything the second
of all how did you who started off and
still work in the world of physics and
mathematics end up creating at least the
name for the intellectual darkweb you
did it I know we're on stage together
when it happened so what's the backstory
here well I think it's actually sort of
an interesting one I have been tracking
various political and social issues
since the 1980s and have inserted myself
or fought through a number of topics
including high-skilled immigration
mortgage-backed securities and various
issues having to do with my concerns
over the loss of objectivity in the
major press organs so in some ways this
is not my first rodeo there have been a
few before and what's been really
interesting for me is that this is the
first one where I've had great company
so a lot of these previous iterations
have been really one or two people like
Nassim Taleb was a co-fighter in the
mortgage-backed security question and a
guy named norm Matloff was one of the
few people who is really a critic of
high-skilled immigration from an
intelligent position so what's really
interesting about this is that this is
the first time that there's a large
number of interesting voices with a few
new technologies and and wrinkles to
explore and I think the best thing I
could think to do with so many
independent voices was to try to use
language to identify what was already
occurring and have the language sort of
help people see what was already
happening and that would allow it us to
direct this a little bit for more more
powerfully what do you think has changed
what sort of brought all of this
together because obviously it's pretty
politically disparate group you're on
the political left you voted Democrat I
believe virtually all the time no I
don't think I've ever voted never okay
so yeah so you're on the left and you
know obviously your brother Brett who's
a member of the IDW in good standing
he also is on the left people like Sam
Harris are on the left and then I may be
the only overt conservative in the group
actually I think it's been it's been
actually perceived as this wild
right-wing group and as far as I know
I'm the only registered Republican in
the group so far as I know and I think
that has to do with the fact that
something very peculiar happened on the
left and so in many ways this is a
response from an older left to what is
viewed as almost certainly a very brief
very intense and very crazy bout of bad
judgment I would say from the American
left it's not that these strains haven't
been present before but what's really
new to me is the idea that this new sort
of woke Network which practices
something which I've called left car
theism has invaded the major organs of
civil society and the most important
examples of this I would say first and
foremost is not the universities but the
major media companies that are form our
sense-making Network so news bureaus
let's say the next thing that's infected
in my opinion is the tech companies that
are public facing which are under
constant pressure to show that they are
sufficiently in line with what are
called progressive values but I think
most of us with a longer timeline would
say we're very regressive values in the
intelligence community which you know
scares me no end almost certainly has a
relationship with these tech companies
given that we deposit all our secrets
into our gmail accounts and our browsing
histories is you were just talking about
in your latest plug you know all of
these things are come together in what I
call Tim technology intelligence and
media the universities are a certain or
certainly a serious problem but I think
the most important problem is that we
can't trust our sense making organs
because you know as we just I tweeted
out today the New Yorker you know ran a
tweet saying conservative orders like my
Louie innopolis Ben Shapiro and Richard
Spencer and then dot dot and I thought
wow I mean you
put ben shapiro next to Richard Spencer
as if none of us are gonna notice what
you just did this has gotten really
dirty really negative and conservatives
have complained about excesses on the
left for a long time and I think that's
been fair but I also think that there
have been a lot of excesses on the right
what we're seeing is something really
really new the the the new left is much
more dangerous and I think those of us
on the on the old left who weren't happy
with some of these strands before take
it upon ourselves to say how do we clean
this up this is in some sense our
problem and you know that that was not
fair to do to you so if the New Yorkers
not going to apologize to you I prefer
not to apologize I'm just gonna fight
back because it's just not right that's
all for this week's Sunday special if
you've enjoyed hearing from our past
guests in this collection be sure to
check out their full episodes and hear
more of the conversation links to those
are in our description also be sure to
leave us a comment about who some of
your favorite past Sunday special guests
have been and who you'd like to see me
talk with next season thanks for
listening gang
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
produced by Mathis clever executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Katie Swinton our guests are
booked by Kaitlyn Manor post-production
is supervised by Alex and Singaram
editing is by Jim Nichol audio is mixed
by Mike Romina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva title
graphics are by Cynthia and Gullu the
Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
[Music]